probably. I thought maybe she was talking to a chatter there.
She is not talking to a chatter there. See carrier, this is where
you are um being an energy vampire. Energy vampires, go away.
I have I have energy vampire garlic. I will never be I will never
fall into this trap again. I am not I have absolutely zero idea
what is going I If she's having like a stroke there, like a mini
stroke, you can't get me, vampire. You can't get me. I do not
invite you into my house. I do not invite you into my house,
vampire. Leave. Leave my doorstep. You're not fighting you under
I don't I don't know. I don't know. I It actually It may be rude
to comment on whatever the happened right there. I don't I don't
know. I guess to give you more lore, this happened because Idubbbz
is a famous YouTuber and he made a video called Content Nuke
and it was on H3H3 and it was just I have the one with all the
tech issues. It makes it a little funnier, but your call. Oh,
I forgot that she just had tech issues the whole time she and
making fun of Ethan for crashing out and kind of just it wasn't
it wasn't the best. Look, I used to be a fan of the content cop.
Okay, I liked it. Thought it was I thought it was a decent bit.
Really? I don't believe Kylo is like an old school fan of I I
have no reason to suspect this isn't true. I just have I I just
don't believe that she like is a fan of old YouTube or old YouTube
lore. Like I don't think she knows any of those creators. I just
I don't think so. I just don't think so. Not not the best content
on YouTube, by the way. That's me just mind reading. That's just
my read. Okay. I'm like I don't think so. I really really don't
think so. But that that is based on nothing. That is just unhinged.
Like I just I feel like there's no way. Uh but I don't have I
don't have an argument. Okay. I don't have an argument. I think
she was pretty online. I don't think she was pretty online. I
think she got introduced to being pretty online by Nick. I think.
But you know what? We'll we'll let it go. We'll let it play.
Um, now Eli, thank you for the sub. Thank you for the gifted
membership. I appreciate that. Now it's not, uh, it's not doing
so hot. Hey guys, you guys are back. Thanks, Eli. So, uh, he
drops this hour and 42 and predictably
predictably he expects that there will be a bunch of content
creators who hate him who are going to watch it. In fact, H3
Snark, a horrible
Reddit page that I'm surprised, there probably shouldn't be Reddit
pages dedicated to just on one content creator. Call me woke,
call me soy, but it seems probably unhealthy for platform. Okay.
One, Idubbbz. Idubbbz's video got significantly more views than
Ethan Klein's video. Okay. One. So, you're saying it's not doing
so well. Uh, it got a ton of views. It got a ton of views. ton
of watch time, probably made him a ton of money. Okay, now listen.
When you say there shouldn't be subreddits dedicated to hating
a content creator, do we all know how that comes about? Because
it comes about in the exact same way every single time.
Do you know how it comes about? Cuz it's very easy to understand
how it comes about if you think about it at all. I'm going to
give chat
10 seconds, 20 seconds to think about why why snark credits come
about, okay? because it's very easy to track over
Oh, yay. Got it. Yay. Got it. So, here's the here's the progression
that happens. Somebody is a huge fan, okay? Streamer or content
creator does something they don't like, okay? They want to complain
about it. They go to the community to complain about it. They
get banned. they eventually if it is bad enough and they are
a large enough group form a community around that shared like
dislike of what that creator did. Okay, but if you if you weren't
banning these people, if you were actually letting them participate
in your community, you can say, "Oh, well, you can't let that
fester in your community, that might really bother you." But
if you ban all of those people, they will eventually form a community
around their dislike of you. Especially if you have a very large
community and you are banning around a specific event. That's
like 100% what happens. That's like not even confusing to anybody
on the planet. Oh, what's up, Shimsky? How's it going? I guess
you're on vacation, too. Watching the stream on vacation. I love
it. They start making local jokes about Notate, being cringe
and performative. I wanted to make it clear it is not a a base
weight joke. Okay. All right. Oh, I see. You're You're not trying
to uh make fun of her for being a cow. You're just saying she's
a low cow. I got it. Wants to just allow an entire space of just
like haters to exist. like you don't need to ban any of the the
channels the the the Redditors within it, but probably just shouldn't
exist. I think if there's like directed targeted harassment coming
from like the same Reddit group all I think if they are I think
probably I wouldn't mind H3 Snark potentially getting banned
if they are going here's how you uh here's how you watch Ethan
and do not give him money. Here's how you consistently like lose
money. I wouldn't mind a rule against that, but it wouldn't be
a rule against criticism. It wouldn't be a rule against you can't
have a subreddit that criticizes a certain creator. I would say
if they're touching the poo, okay, if they are going after that
creator in some way, if they're coordinating harassment in some
way, then that's where it starts to get bad, right? If they were
like, "Oh, somebody should call CPS." And they made a threat
about, "Hey, let's all call CPS or like that is where it gets
bad." But I think that is already against Reddit's rules. All
right? Like brigading for harassment is already against Reddit's
rules. They can already be banned for that. And I don't know
if Snark has done that without banning people. I would imagine
given all the eyes on them. They have had a fairly strong way
of going and saying like, "Hey, um, we're going to ban you for
this. Hey, we're hey, you're like directing harassment. We're
going to ban you. We're going to ban you. We're going to ban
you. We're going to ban you." Like that seems to be how this
stuff works. Okay. Anyway,
um I don't even know where I was going. I read a [__]
comment. Targeted her. Oh yes. Uh, Stark, I think, have to basically
be following Reddit's rules or they have to be making an effort
because I think they would be terminated if they were not. They
literally already told Ethan they aren't going to ban it because
his subreddit is the same. Aren't going to ban what? Like the
criticism or the like uh being unhinged towards him. Like I think
sort of being unhinged, quote unquote, really helps you not delineate
behavior in any way. Some behavior is banworthy. Some behavior
is criticism and justified criticism that shouldn't be banned.
Right? When you just say, "Oh, they're unhinged and obsessed."
That is you not wanting to make a real argument about why they
should be banned, right? You want to glob them all together,
take the worst people of them and and apply the label to the
whole group. That's what you want to do, right? You should have
some argument over what they're actually saying and what they're
actually doing. Like at least Ethan, when he goes to make this
post or when he goes to make this lawsuit, he's explaining why
he doesn't like them and why they've like wronged him, right?
That they've set up like uh methods to siphon money from him.
That they have uh promoted creators who will help siphon money
from him. that they seem very directed in their mission to siphon
money from him. That is why he feels like he should be able to
attach them to this lawsuit. I think that makes sense. That's
a totally justified reason to hate this subreddit, right? I think
I would even support rules against that being on Reddit that
if you're going to set up like a bunch of people to come to a
space where you're very critical of this person, here's how you
can actually steal their their work. Yeah, that that's stupid.
But here's the thing. How does Aerodite support that? How does
Eerite say that that's like evil when she must know? She must
be aware that the Destiny community does the same thing to Hassan,
right? I'll have you know that essentially all I would say 95%
of the time I reacted to Hassan, I would explicitly not re if
even if I was streaming with the Destiny community watching me,
right? I would not do it like direct live almost ever. I would
very very very rarely do it direct live um because I I felt like
that was probably wrong to do, right? I wouldn't like people
doing that to me. So, I go to the VOD and I start at the beginning
of where he started like crashing out about something and I just
stream it from there. So, but the Destiny community, there are
people in that community in on DGG who will set up like a mirrored
stream to just stream his content and cut cut money away from
him to to siphon money away from him, right? There is nothing
that the Destiny community does that H3 Snark uh or there's nothing
H3 Snark does that I don't think the Destiny community does in
some way, right? Like I I think so I I just don't understand
the the pure criticism for Snark while aligning with the Destiny
community. I just don't I don't get it personally. I do get the
criticisms for Snark though and I think specifically the money
thing. I would love to see a rule against that on Reddit. You
can't like you can't be a a subreddit set up to explicitly take
money away from somebody. That's been coming from like the same
Reddit group all the time. You guys banned the incel groups and
they were doing a lot less of that. They were just being misogynists,
okay? Psycho misogynists.
But in this case, H3 Snark is like actively directing malicious
stuff towards Ethan. So anyways, I feel like there there are
people like like Lav or Max are just sitting here and are like,
"Really? That's where your line is? A subreddit consistently
making like unhinged posts about one creator and directing like
hate their way? A community set up that is basically like all
the time directing unhinged hate towards these people. That's
where you draw the line. That's where you draw That's Kyla. That's
where you draw the line. Kyla, that's where the line is drawn.
Kyla. Kyla. Hello. Reddit used to allow everything. Well, yeah,
but then it banned a bunch of those like uh incel channels and
a couple of other like white supremacy channels and stuff, which
I'm not necessarily disagreeing with, but uh really. So, anyways,
this content nuke drops and predictably
H3 Snark releases a whole bunch of channels that are planning
to cover Ethan's
content. Sorry, I keep going here because my stream deck is it's
just not set up yet. Predictably, he knows that they're going
to cover this. However, a bunch of these haters, Froggen, all
these leftist types who really hate Ethan because he's not psychotic
about Israel enough. And oh, wait. When you uh when you start
this time stamp here, Ry, will you give me this time stamp? Are
we like most of the way through the video? Am I not watching
most of her reaction to the video? Looks like she's all the way
through this video, basically. Am I missing like all of her reaction
to the video here or because I wouldn't mind getting like more
of their reaction to the video? I'm just curious with this time
stamp exactly where it is. No, she just started. Okay. Okay.
All right. Sorry. I'll back it up. Because he's not psychotic
about Israel enough. And Ethan has also been like uh antagonistic
uh towards them. He's done a number of things that I think are
like Ethan's general positions don't make sense for somebody
who believes that there's a genocide being perpetrated against
the Gazins specifically or the Palestinians as a whole. His his
positions don't make sense. The thing the things he's upset about
don't make sense. Probably too far, but it's almost always reactive
to them. I don't think he's like going after people initially.
You know what? You're right. Meowzilla killer. You are You are
right. When you're right, you're right. Okay. When you're right,
you're right. I need to actually set this up again. Uh 60 hair.
Go like this and stream hours plus two. I think I had three from
Riyle here for today. Okay, stream hours plus two. Okay, there's
a there's a goal. We have to get rid of the carrier goal. We
are not getting subs with the carrier goal, guys. It is not helping.
Okay, not a good plan. That that is off. We are back to just
the two hours on the stream. Okay. Jesus. Um like hardly at all.
So, psychonauts psych psycho psycho psycho gent. Exactly. He
actually apparently registers this video legally so that if you
take it and use it, it's under fair use and you have to oh transform
it. How so? As opposed to what would normally happen where you
can just steal any content from anybody with nothing uh with
no downside. Okay. Ethan has legally registered it so that you
have to do fair use. You have to transform it for fair use. Usually
you don't have to transform it for fair use. It's totally fine
if you don't transform it for fair use. However, you can't cover
it if it's under certain clauses. It's protected. Okay, I'll
just it. I'll just show you. So, he drops this content nuke predictably
knowing that people are going to cover it and use it. It's under
fair use and you have to transform it. However, you can't cover
it if it's under certain clauses.
You can't cover it if it's under certain clauses. What are these
clauses that you can't cover it under? I actually don't even
know. I brother
sister what are you doing?
Oh dude, do we have to listen to the whole thing again? So psychots
psych psycho psycho psycho. Exactly. He actually apparently registers
this video legally so that if you take it and use it, it's so
he registers the video legally. If you take it and use it, it's
under fair use. Fair use. And you have to transform it. However,
you can't So all so just I I'll just correct. So all that changes
when you legally register it is you gain access well all that
I am aware of I should say that changes when you legally register
it is you gain access to statutory damages. Okay. You gain access
to statutory damages um that are set up if for any infringement
I think at oh I don't remember the lower bound now. Is it like
like 500 to like $5,000 or something? And then the upper limit
I think is like uh up to $150,000.
So, if you're sorry if you're willfully infringing, you get statutory
damages of up to $150,000 per violation. Okay, that is why he's
registered it because he wants to he wants to be able to sue
these people and actually cause like significant financial harm.
Uh he would be able to sue them in any case, but only for the
actual damages. This the change that's been done here by pre-registering
is that, you know, now you can sue for statutory damages and
get your legal fees recouped if you win. He's got pretty strong
cases. These are basically just free money for him. Okay? at
least very specifically the Froggen the Froggen one and the Caseyron
one. I think that's more or less free money for him. Okay. And
they they almost certainly they should settle. I don't know if
they will. Casey will for sure. But um I don't think Denims has
to. I think Denims could I think Denims could make him blink.
I I feel like he might drop the suit against Denims to be honest
with you. I feel like I feel like if Denims just calls him on
it and says like whatever, if he's going to sue me, he's going
to sue me. And he could just blink. We'll see. Okay. See, carrier,
this is where you are um being an energy vampire. Energy vampires,
go away. I have I have energy vampire garlic. I will never be
I will never fall into this trap again. I am not You can't get
me, vampire. You can't get me. I do not invite you into my house.
I do not invite you into my house, vampire. Leave. Leave my doorstep.
Inviting you under certain clauses. It's protected. Okay, I'll
just I'll just You can't cover it under certain clauses. It's
protected. that none of that is actually what the case is for
registering. It does. I don't think any of that made sense. I
could be wrong. I think none of that essentially 0% of what she
just said is actual fact. So, he drops this content nuke predictably
knowing that people are going to cover it. And wouldn't you have
it, friends of the stream, truly dear friends, decide to cover
it in full and H3 Snark directs people to their pages to watch
it elsewhere so that they can watch the full content nuke but
not give any views, which is crazy. I mean, another way to formulate
that would be these people despise Ethan's content and are only
looking for people who will be critical of it and or transform
in some way that is like mocking Ethan. That they are not looking
for the product of Ethan Klein. They're looking for the product
of anybody who's mocking Ethan Klein would be another way of
looking at it. I don't think that'll work in court though. That's
just a trust me that's just a you know what would you call it?
Like a devil's advocate what her lawyers are going to argue.
I don't think that's a good argument but it is. It is an
Palestine in Israel probably. What I am I missing everything
here views which is crazy. Which is crazy
elsewhere so that they can watch the So oh yes, H3 Snark is directing
them to watch it elsewhere. Watch it through Denims or whoever
so that they can prevent him from getting views nuke but not
give any views.
Which is crazy. Which is crazy.
Palestine in Israel probably. I thought maybe she was talking
to a chatter there. She is not talking to a chatter there. I
have absolutely zero idea what is going I if she's having like
a stroke there like a mini stroke. I don't I don't know. I don't
know. I it actually it may be rude to comment on whatever the
happened right there. I don't I don't know. Rewind. I want to
see it again. We watch the whole thing. it elsewhere so that
they could watch them watch it content nuke. So they could watch
the full content any views but not give any views which is crazy
because because because because
Palestine and Israel probably Israel and Palestine. Hold on.
Listen, we got to we got I should I should just for this entire
segment hold on I got to be on this page. Okay. This is like
a red bar segment now. Okay. Um hold on. Let me pull up my stream
deck thing so I can actually hear it. I know you guys can hear
it. I cannot. We're gonna we're gonna have to have this up the
whole time. Okay. We're gonna drive this into the ground. Screenshot.
No. I Dude, I just Israel Palestine would be a good one. Would
be a good one. Okay. So, anyways, Ethan dastardly planner as
he is.
I
Is she not going to say it was like because because because
and then I I Where are we going? I She had a point to make. Did
she just Why? That happens to everybody. Everybody can have a
brain fart. You just say, "Oh, I had a brain fart there. I just
lost where I was going." Whoops.
Why not just say that? Why? Why do whatever this was is psychotic.
Comes up with a ploy. All right. Ethan comes up with a ploy.
Hold on. That music's not too obtrusive, right? The the music's
pretty low in the sound levels. Yes, I think the music's pretty
low in the sound levels. We should be good with this music. I
hope it's not too obtrusive. Okay. Ethan is
Oh. Oh, we have no audio. I see. Ollie kick flip. Thank you for
the 19 months. Let's go. So funny. Okay. So, he goes through
he outlines his content nuke and what he expected.
You know, I'm not going to cover the whole video. You can just
go watch it. There's so many people that have covered it. And
this in part stems off of a debate that he had with Felix or
XQC
about fair use. Um there's this we're on a firstname basis, Felix.
We're on a first name basis. more than a year ago at this point
amongst H3 and say like video essaists uh H3 was taking the video
essay side and react content creators like Asmin Gold XQC uh
people who majority of their content is watching other people's
content and okay okay okay
we are locked in now we have made several comments in a row that
are
that are pretty accurate that are like we're locked in now we've
had like two to three statements in a row that have been accurate.
I think we're going to get the ball rolling now. It's going to
be a normal stream. We're going to get like actual
sensical commentary. Okay. I think so, right? Which a lot of
people like React content is like some of the most popular content
consumed. Asmin Gold is a really good example of this. He's the
most popular political streamer and he's mostly just doing React
content. And there's a really big issue that happens that a lot
of video essays will make brilliant work that will get watched
by a React YouTuber, React streamer. the rack streamer will basically
add nothing to the video. They'll upload the video in full without
really even giving them any praise or redirection.
And the transformative element, which is essential for fair use,
is uh not the greatest. It'll be a lot of like, wow,
oh no, it'll be mostly like that. Their eyebrows will go the
classic streamer eyebrow going up move. Yes, the classic. Very
engaging.
Very interesting. I know. Uh, listen, this is compared to before.
This is way better, okay? Where she just like had no idea what
she at least this is like somewhat accurate. Yes, these reactions
were not transformative. They were very poorly done. They added
very little content. They didn't really change it in any way.
They weren't commentary. They weren't criticism. It was really
just them watching the video, okay? Them watching the video,
them stealing the title, thumbnail, and putting it all together.
Okay? So, anyways, this stems off of this debate.
And there are, as many of you would probably know, no ethics
or rules on YouTube really about this. You can copyright strike
each other a little bit. No, you can totally DMCA people. You
can absolutely DMCA people. Um, and I believe YouTube, if somebody's
like reacting to your videos, I believe YouTube just pops up
and says, "Hey, this is your video." They're like reacting to
your video. As long as it's content that's on YouTube, you will
get a notification if it's like using a sign significant portion
of your content. that there's things that you can do, but the
reality is that it's pretty much unmanaged and unmititigated.
And that's not true. That's literally not true at all. That the
DMCA totally exists. YouTube will literally say, "Here's your
options for DMCAing this. You can you can directly like try to
copyright strike these people. You can directly do these things.
You can directly like do whatever you want. You give them just
a DMCA notice and say, "Hey, you have three days to take it down."
You you just automatically get to do that. And especially if
you're some of the largest channels, for example, there are a
lot of YouTubers that could watch Jubilee.
I cannot.
And I I thought the I thought the commentary from people was
XQC gets to do this and even big creators are scared to DMCA
XQC because they do not want smoke from his community. It wasn't
that they are unaware or they can't do anything. It was there
is a like there is a force differential here. Okay. that if they
complain about XQC, they're very scared the juicers will like
start downloading all their [__] They'll start talking
[__] They'll start harassing them. That's what people
are worried about. That was the argument with XQC. It wasn't
that he couldn't be DMCA. His argument was literally in in response
was just DMCA. If you don't like that, if you don't like that,
just DMCA B. And nobody was like, "No, no, no. They they couldn't
possibly there's no tool to do that." Nobody argued there's no
tool to do that. They said, "No, uh they're concerned about how
your community will react to that cuz you have a massive community."
Ah, I've tried transforming it in multiple ways. I've tried making
sure that I only watch little bits at a time. I can't do it.
But wait, how is she arguing that it's like unmanaged then? What?
What do you mean unmanaged? It sounds like Jubilee is managing
this. It sounds like you literally can't react to their that
you get notices. How I don't know how you could argue that this
is largely unmanaged when you stream on YouTube and you will
literally get a
announcement to your streaming dashboard saying hey if you keep
streaming this content that you don't have the copyright access
to you will be taken down your stream will be taken down I where
is she what doesn't Jubilee content ID they definitely do yeah
she's complaining about that it's like she was just arguing that
it's a largely unmanaged problem on YouTube and then she was
explaining that oh I can't even react to this channel because
it's like basically automated that I get taken down. I think
she's right because even if it's transformative, there's no rule
in place. So, Jubilee will be super selective. Jubilee DMC is
everything and you can counter claim it if you want, if you think
it's transformative enough. But the risk in counter claiming
is that you risk actually going to law or sorry, you risk going
to court, right? If you counter claim, you say, "Here's my identity.
Take me to court if you actually think that this is a DMCA offense."
And nobody wants to do it, right? Nobody wants to. Uh, even Chud
Logic when he was doing the Dark Viper stuff and I believe that
he was not really engaging in any bad practice. I believe that
he was very much transformative. It was substantial reactions
to essentially every part of Dark Viper's video. He almost tripled
the length of the video. He refused to take that to court. He
didn't counter claim. He just said, you know what? I'm just not
going to react to this guy anymore. That's that's what he did,
right? It's but it's absolutely managed and anybody can do this.
So, I don't know where where we're coming from with the whole
no no. You can't you can't do anything about this on YouTube.
The problem with XQC is that he goes to Twitch and he streams
it and there is no corresponding system on Twitch. That's where
the problem is, right? There's a DMCA system, but there it is
like basically personally managed. Somehow content creators over
at least 700K just magically can. Very interesting. Okay, so
YouTube unsurprising.
Wait, now hold on. Is she arguing that Jubilee doesn't have the
right to manage their own copyright? It's totally within Jubilee's
rights to grant a license to whoever they want. What are you
talking about? Like they're obviously granting licenses to these
people by not going after them, right? I thought isn't that her
side's argument is is basically like you get to manage your copyright
however you want. You can target whoever you want if they're
doing it. You can grant a license to whoever you want. I think
that's
I mean I broadly agree with all of those things. Not even-handed
in the fair use policy. You can copyright strike people, but
that's basically a way to just admit that you're a okay. If you
copyright strike people a lot, you're mostly going to get a video
made about you. And yeah, sometimes it works. I I think people
are incredibly fair. Like most of the people I'm aware of who
talk about the copyright strike stuff, most of the people I know
who talk about this stuff, uh Chud is probably the first person
over the Dark Viper things, the Dark Dark Viper content. I feel
like he was totally fair in how he analyzed that. I think even
in this case, a lot of people look at this and they go, Ethan
can totally do that. He is kind of a [__] Okay, but
is this right? I I I don't think anybody looks at them and goes
like, "Oh, like I don't think anybody looked at Ethan copyright
striking Caseyron when she basically just re like rebroadcast
all of his and goes, oh, you're like a total [__]
for this, right? Especially if he DMCA those streams or anything.
Nobody would get mad. Nobody' get mad. They're just trying to
steal Caseron's just trying to steal his content. That's it.
Some people lose their content, but not the stream up. Most of
really uhoh. What? It's been running the whole time like often
enough. It is considered transformative which is crazy. So what
do we have to establish any level of rights of it? There it is
in the streaming industry. It's lawsuits. And unfortunately the
only people who can do lawsuit Wait, hold on. You're like infinitely
more of a [__] for going directly to lawsuits instead
of DMCAing something. You're like infinitely more of a [__]
You That's like infinitely more invasive. Yeah, literally nobody
would be mad at Ethan if he DMCA this content. Nobody. Zero people
would be mad if he DMCA Denim's stream. If he DMCA Caseron stream,
Froggen stream, he could have DMCA all of those streams and there
would be zero criticism for him. They were taking his content.
Uh I think Denims was probably transforming it, but it is well
within his rights to DMCA and then say if you want to take me
to court over this cuz you think it's transformative, go ahead.
E, right, Macho, thank you for the gifted sub.
Nobody, nobody would have been about DMCA's in the same way that
they're about lawsuits. Lawsuits are like an escalation. This
is like Aerodite saying, "Listen, if you, you know, if you're
in a border dispute with another country and you fire a bullet
over the line, you're a bitch." Okay? The international community
calls you a [__] But if you fire, if you fire a missile
at their capital, then that's the only way to deal with it. Okay?
You couldn't fire a bullet back. You just fire a missile at their
capital. That's the only way to deal with it. It's like, "No,
one of the they're basically the exact same action. One is just
a massive escalation, right? You're trying to prevent this person
from taking your copyright or you're trying to prevent this person
from infringing on your copyright. One is a preventative act
that says like, hey, you have to take that down now. You are
infringing on my copyright. The other is like, I just want money
from you. I want to with you, but they're the same. They're the
same action. You're trying to protect your copyright suits is
rich YouTubers. It's very hard to do a lawsuit when you are a
poor like me. Look, if there are people there are people who
will watch all of my content before I can ever release it, I
would love to not have them do that kind of. Hey,
I'm watching this way after you released it. Okay, this is like
9 days old. There's no way I'm stealing money from her. There
is 0% chance I'm stealing money from her. I don't I listen, she
kind of calling me out here, I think, but I'm not I I'm literally
pausing like nearly everything she's saying. Brother, I'm going
to be here for hours. That takes away from me. Look, you can
hate watch me. I don't care. Just watch me on my channel. Don't
hate watch me elsewhere, you [__] Okay, bring your
hatred here. Okay, I want it. I love it. I bathe in your tears.
Doesn't Jubilee have a react that you can purchase. Sorry. I
think the silence the lack of commentary there is better. React
probably. I wouldn't be surprised. I'm also not gonna buy it.
Sorry. No, that's stupid. Um, because again, I'm not anti-react
content. Clearly, I do react content. What I do think is cringe
is when large channels will cover somebody else's video and then
they give no shoutouts. They watch it in full. Often times, guys,
okay? If you want to watch the content directly, they'll on it
and see that. Oh, we see we see that we see. And this is what
it's like all going to come down to, right? I don't like being
criticized on the internet. I don't like being criticized on
the internet. I don't like being criticized on the internet.
I hate being criticized on the internet. We can all see what
the real problem is. It's I'm being criticized on the internet.
We don't like it. Kickap is such trash. Well, we're over on Twitch
if you do want to watch their macho. and they release the entirety
of the video on their own channel with like minimal transformation.
So, I don't mind I don't mind people watching my content. And
she's really referring to Queenman. Okay. She's like, "It's really
unreasonable. This guy has like 8 minutes of dead air between
comments on my video and then he just says that dead air that
silences like the font of creativity." That's really not a that's
not actually a valid thing to say. Okay, that's up. That's crazy
to go with. Okay, that's that's just nuts. I'm obviously kidding.
I'm obviously kidding. Queen can turn a 30-minute aerodynite
video into like a 6-hour video. Okay, it's fine. It's fine. Okay,
I don't know why I'm leaning into that meme. I don't even really
think that meme's true most of the time I watch him. Okay, she
just she doesn't like criticism and I think most of my videos
where I'm watching Erdite, she says enough like dumb things that
I can pause constantly. I can just always be
AP. Okay. Brand new disorder. Okay. ABP. Always be pausing. We're
always pausing. Okay. Is the foot mirror back? Yeah, but it's
not angled at her feet. So, it's okay. Okay. But by the way,
adding stuff to it isn't just going, "Wow, she's so dumb. She
said a dumb stupid thing." That No. No. What I'm meaning here
is some substantive addition, right? Some Yeah. Like pointing
out that what she said isn't basically when she does like misinformation
about like what registering the copyright does. I can just explain
to you what it actually does. I think that's substantively adding.
Yeah, I think so. I think that's like very relevant. Actually,
you know, if I say something that you think is wrong, you do
at least the work of to outline why you think I'm wrong, not
just to say I'm a stupid [__] And so, let's go. There
are a lot of you video essayists who very understandably hate
React content creators because I remember a conversation with
Sneo. One of the reasons that Sneo first grifted into the streaming
red pill space is because he made this great video essay on women.
Hassan
watched it, barely said anything, grunted for the most part,
and then ended by saying misogynist and his vid. You think she
is actually watching any of this content? Um, I don't know. She
certainly I So, it's weird because I know that she is aware that
I cover her stuff, but I don't think she's like aware of the
content of what I cover. She'll just talk about it and say like
I'm unhinged or obsessed. She's like I think she said something
a couple weeks ago. It was like this guy's the most unhinged
like crazy person I've ever seen. She was like talking. She alternates
between me or Queen being her like nemesis I guess. But she doesn't
actually outline like what we did wrong or like outline commentary
that she disagrees with. Anyway, video got more views than Sneo's
original video which took him three months to make and film and
script. So, it's a little understandable that video essayists
get a little bitter, especially if there is no redirection, there's
no promotion. Also, in general, I think it's pretty good form
to try to leave at least like 20% of the video unwatched. And
most importantly, I think Abram Preach probably do some of the
best react content where they only show you little clips before
that are relevant to what they're saying. They That probably
is fair that you should only use the clip. You should pre-screen
content and uh but that is not really a reaction. So that Gokanara
video about Sneo is so good. If only he hadn't disappeared from
the internet. I actually think he did a video on Ethan Klein
recently. He did like a stream. Did anybody watch that stream?
I watched it for a little bit and then I unfortunately it was
like right when I was going to sleep so I fell asleep. Like I
I literally was like in bed for a while. I was like, "Oh, I'm
going to go to sleep." And then I somehow somebody linked it
to me and I clicked on it and I was like I was already gone.
But uh I watched Queen and watch it. Oh, I was it like good?
Like, sorry. I just I don't know what he was talking about. I
don't mean was it good. I think I broadly like respect Okinaro's
opinions, right? He usually is pretty researched, but I just
don't know. Um I don't know what he was talking about. Am I wrong?
If you dislike a video and like the video, you're probably just
directing harassment. Oh, that could be true, right? If if you
were to like Yeah, when I said her URL, I'm definitely not directing
har I'm not trying to do that. Yeah, it is kind of difficult.
Yeah, I don't know. Critical critical commentary.
There are a lot of unhinged people though, okay, in this chat.
A lot of very unhinged people. Certainly doesn't help when Riyle
goes and donates to her to try to rile her up over different
things. Okay, you're not helping. You're not helping anybody.
They never kind of show you the video in full. So, if you want
to watch the video in full, totally disavow rile harassing Nerite.
Okay, total disavowel. Complete disavow. You have to go and I
think a preach will link you to the video that they're reacting
to below in the description. I think that is like the highest
standard of React content. um that is the most ethical thing
to do and then there's stuff in between. All right, that's the
background of the free use debate. All right, fair use. Free
use is the bracelet you wear to let people know that you can
get at any time. Fair use is the copyright standard. So, he gets
into that. I'm not going to cover all of this because holy, everyone
already has. All right, he releases the content nuke where we're
going to get to the good stuff. Okay, audio is still not working.
Didn't notice that the audio wasn't working before, but
Oh, Ethan. So cool. Watch us here. Please share and like the
stream. Thanks, Poo. Thanks for the two. Can we go over the four
pillars of free use?
We call that your arms and legs. Okay. All right. Jesus. Uh,
what do you guys mean no sound? I'm watching sound. What's up,
little Wubby? How's it going? What? Some technical issues here.
I'll zoom in. It is absolutely showing that it's grabbing sound.
I will try to reset it. Wait, how could OBS be showing you that
it's grabbing sound but it not be like actually transcoding sound?
I actually don't understand how that could be possible. Uh, what?
Maybe it's a video. Hold on. Maybe it doesn't look weird with
this video. Oh. Oh, she might have the source monitored and muted.
Muting the output on a monitored source. That would have to be
the That would be the only way that it would show audio but not
be outputting the audio to the stream. Oh, yeah. Is this the
video where Asgold talks about not showering? Yeah, that what
she clicked on. Uh, what? Maybe
this video about my mom. Oh, this must be where husband Gold's
mom passed away. That sucks. Uh, that sucks. Can you guys hear
that? This doesn't even make sense. Desktop audio. It's coming
in. I uh don't even know how to make a video like this. I don't
know how to make like this. I don't even What? Wait, you can
do it on Twitch. Wait, hold on. I don't know what's going on.
They just I'm actually just editing. I'm jumping off a bridge.
Okay, [__] I should have closed my tab. Good luck
editing this. Have fun. Have fun, buddy. You're welcome. Isn't
it fun being an editor? Oh my gosh, it's so fun. Okay, what if
I could Here's the time stamp of the cherry. Let's go. Han is
bad. Han is bad. Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Is very bad. Couldn't
resist avoid the temptation. Don't you guys know Hassan is bad.
I don't have issue with you. It's not that these people. Also,
very sorry to my Twitch fans, guys. We're going to go kick only
for the rest of the stream. Kick only for the rest of the stream.
Go over to kick kick.com/jk.
Hop over there. We're watching this uh this airite video on Ethan
Klein. All right. I'm shutting off multireaming and we are exiting
the Twitch stream, guys. Head over. We'll see you in just a minute.
Okay. I'll wait a second before I start up the video again. Okay,
I'm waiting for you all to switch over.
Lot says, "Nope." Well, that's unfortunate, Low Tech, but I unfortunately
make way more money if I don't stream with Twitch on. So, good
luck. Good luck. Good luck. Good luck. Unlucky for him. Where's
my Twitch [__]
Let me put a link in here. We'll pin that. Oh, he actually says,
"We'll see you over there." Okay, well, cool. Yeah, we'll go
20 minutes. Perfect. Head over to kick. Be on kick. Watch kick.
Always watch kick. Do my video. I knew they would. I knew they
would watch the entire video, had little to no commentary, react
to it instantly, giving them no time to form an opinion. The
trap was set and it worked even better than I imagined it would.
We captured pretty much every large screen reacting to it in
its entirety immediately after it was. Now, the thing is I had
it on 2x, but she hasn't commenting, so we're a few people that
went above and beyond to commit copyright infringement. For example,
Denim sits here silently with nearly 50,000 live viewers. That's
30 times her regular viewership. She's working directly with
the Snark subreddit moderators to siphon views and their intention.
Guys,
this is
like this is
Um, I would so I should differentiate here. I don't like that
this subre exists doing this. I personally don't like this. Okay,
it there should never be a thing where it's like, "Oh, I want
to hurt this this creator's bottom line and I don't add anything
and I'm just going to like hurt this creator's bottom line."
I do think that's bad. This arc subate shouldn't exist. It shouldn't
be here. These people, okay? Uh these people, if they do this,
if you just keep it to criticism of Ethan, I'm cool with you
guys, okay? But if you're just like, "Oh, how can we maliciously
direct away any views from this guy?" Yeah, you okay? It's a
little crazy. Now, it's not crazy for the reason that Ethan implies
that like they're working directly with Denims. That is not there's
no proof of that here anywhere. Okay? Like I I had no idea this
happened. Hey everyone, we said a lot in the comments about wanting
to watch the nuke without showing support for H3.
You can't do that. You can't do that. You can do that. But you
shouldn't. It's like morally wrong. That's bad.
That's bad to do. Why is it showing this for? But as we know
from Erdite's previous statements, somebody can engage in something
bad and we don't actually have to do anything about that or change
anything about that. We could just, you know, keep, you know,
you just say that's bad and then you're morally in the clear,
right? Ever and ever and ever. Hey guys, that was bad. I did
my job. I did my job. What? What is happening? What? What did
I That's bad. What? What did I miss? You can't do that. You can't
do that. Bad. That's bad to do. Why is it showing this forever
and ever and ever?
What happened? Couldn't be clearer. Here's an excerpt from a
stickied post from the snark subreddit. Hey everyone, we I What
happened? What happened? What happened? I've seen a lot of comments
about wanting to watch the nuke without showing support for H3.
Here's a list of creators who have supported our sub, either
by engaging with us directly or citing our post in their critique
of H3. Here they're offering these streamers as market substitutes
for my work. This is the cardinal sin of copyright infringement.
This is the cardinal sin. I think this gets put together with
the first factor. The first factor is generally believed to be
the most important, right? But I I do agree that like market
replacement is important. Sorry guys, I'm sorry. Me snark subing
our post list a lot of comments about wanting to watch the nuke
without showing support for H3. Here's a list of creators who've
supported our sub either by engaging with us directly or citing
our post in their critique of H3. Here there are
I just maybe I overdo it, but like I feel like I can't have a
moment like that and not explain what happened. I think it'd
be even weirder if I did like some weird stmming on stream with
my face visible. Obviously, that wouldn't be the case, but with
my face visible, like doing some weird stmming before just hitting
play and pretending none of that happened. Like, I just feel
streamers as market substitutes for my work. This is Okay, let's
just for a second. I know. I know. Stop screaming. Stop screaming.
If there are audio issues, tell me. If there are just streaming
related issues, leave me alone. I'm over it. Okay. Only tell
me if there are audio issues. I don't I don't care about the
rest. I'm good. I could see the visual stuff. Okay. Okay. Very
quickly, we should commit all of these names to memory because
this behavior, it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter if you hate
someone. It doesn't matter the person.
Okay. Why would you Okay. Why would you commit these names to
memory? Why? What evidence do you have that anybody who's in
this list talked to anybody who's a part of the Snark sub and
said something like, "Could you put me on that list?" Why would
you blame these people for some who you guys are saying that
these mods are unhinged antifans? They are psychotic.
And you're going to blame the insane rantings and ravings of
these unhinged psychotic people on the people they listed here?
That seems unreasonable. You hate suck. It doesn't matter if
they suck more than anyone else on the planet and they are genuinely
the worst and you are fully justified in hating them. You cannot
coordinate to watch their content in such a way so that they
get none of the credit. You can't do that. Where is the coordination?
Coordination implies
like a uh I would say I was going to say quid proquo. That's
not what I meant. I was going to say that and that's silly. It
requires a back and forth. It requires a back and forth. Back
and forth. Back and forth. Back and forth. Where's the evidence
of a back and forth? Where is the evidence of any back and forth?
Even an implicit back and forth. Where is that? It does. And
what is what does she say that is okay to do to these people?
It doesn't matter if you hate someone. It doesn't matter if the
person you hate sucks. It doesn't matter if they suck more than
anyone else on the planet. Okay, hold on. She said commit these
names to memory. That's what I wanted to see. I'm over it. Okay,
I got to restart again. Audio issues. I don't I don't care about
the rest. I'm good. I could see the visual stuff. Why do we need
to commit these names to memory is what I'm looking for. We should
commit all of these names to memory because this behavior, it
doesn't matter. It doesn't matter if you hate someone. It doesn't
matter if the person you hate sucks. It doesn't matter if they
suck more than anyone else on the planet and they are genuinely
You don't thinkly think it's likely they collaborated? I don't
have evidence that they collaborated.
I have evidence that there was like a an environment that Denims
could benefit from. She may have you could even allege that she
is like aware she's taking advantage of that environment. I don't
know to what extent she can be blamed for for these people who
Ethan says are like unhinged sick antisocial degenerate freaks,
right? I don't know how much she could be held responsible for
what they do on their subreddit unless she was explicitly saying,
"No, no, no, make sure you put me in there." Right. I also think
that she almost certainly got more traffic sent to her by Hassan
being off and Hassan's Discord pushing people to her, right?
People in that sphere pushing people to her to watch this video.
The worst. And you were fully justified
in hating them. You cannot coordinate to watch their content
in such a way so that they get none of the credit. You can't
do that. I think it's like uh I think it's obviously really bad.
I think the subreddit people I totally understand. I think that's
really scummy. Would love to see Reddit have a rule against that.
But for Denims, I don't know. Denims is like right at the line
for me where I absolutely hate that she says, "Oh, well, I'm
hope I hope you guys are happy that you didn't give a view to
Ethan." It's disgusting immoral behavior, right? totally disgusting,
totally immoral behavior in my opinion to stream with the intent
of like, "Hey, I know some of these people would go and watch
that content if if uh like somewhere else, right? Would they
watch it through Ethan? I don't know. Would they would they find
another streamer? I don't know." Right? But like she's aware
that streaming that that exact time, that's a like big coup for
her. She'll have a big audience because Osan isn't there. A lot
of people are like looking to her to react to it and give the
criticism of it, right? So, I think she sees it as a big coup.
So, I think if she'd just taken it as like, "Oh, this is a huge
opportunity to to react to this and to give my criticism on the
fly so that Ethan knows that people in this community aren't
scared to react to him." If she'd said something like that, I
would not have like a lot of criticism. I have a lot of criticism
for her having any amount of attitude where she's like, "Yeah,
that guy. I'm happy we're watching this together instead of giving
him any views." Yeah, I think that's disgusting. And all you
have to do when you're a content creator is think of how would
I feel if somebody was doing that to me? If I was publishing
a video I'd worked on for weeks or months and then somebody just
because they hate me, maybe even Ethan Klein's community like
come together, people who are fans of Ethan come together and
direct people away from my stream to other people reacting. How
would I feel about that? Oh, I'd feel pretty. Obviously, whether
they collaborated um or not, Ethan was going to sue them. Collaboration
is most likely not real, but at this point it doesn't matter.
Um
they could have collaborated. I don't think it's like impossible.
I just don't see the evidence of it. If I saw the evidence of
it, I would be interested. That's wrong. It's really, really,
reallyed up. It's reallyed up. That's right. Hate watchers, I
see you. What you're doing all the time. Just to be clear, I
think it's And no, nobody rereams Arodite's stream when it's
live, as far as I know. But, um, well, maybe there's the one
time I got clips, but I think I got clips. In any case, I think
I have total condemnation in a moral sense for denims like gleeully
saying, "Oh, well, I'm glad we all didn't give a view to that."
That's total condemnation, right? Uh I think it's disgusting
and I think the H3 Snark subreddit could easily be I would love
if Reddit had a rule against what they did, right? I don't know
if they violated any rules, okay? But I would love if Reddit
had a rule against what the H3 sub was doing is with regards
to directing people away from supporting Ethan in any way. I
think it's bad. I think Ethan could even I I wouldn't mind if
Ethan sued those people. I do not know if suing Denims here was
appropriate. I don't think I like I I I don't know. I know that
I don't like Ethan suing denims because she was criticizing because
she was criticizing. And I really think the primary chilling
effect I'd look to avoid or the primary chilling effect I want
to to prevent people from adding is a chilling effect against
criticism. Okay. That seems like the worst thing you could do
to me. Okay. Yes. Uh so I don't want to make it seem like I don't
have any criticism for anything going on here. What my criticism
is of this video and of a lot of people's reaction to it is that
they never call out that, hey, where's the proof of coordination?
Where am I getting proof that there is coordination between these
two parties? That's what's alleged. Direct collaboration, direct
coordination, right? They're directly working with each other.
There is no proof of that. It is just alleged without evidence.
I'm ised up. It's not okay. So, just look at these names, okay?
And commit them to memory. Every one of the people who engaged
in such a way that H3 Snark promoted them probably agreed to
this. Maybe not, but very likely did. Very likely the H3 Stark
mods reached out to them telling them about their plan to do
this and they yes manned it. Why? Wait, why is that very likely?
I actually don't know why you would say that's very likely. And
uh just remember all these people, they have literally no principles
at Dude,
there's no way. Hey, I'm alleging a conspiracy with no evidence
that requires multiple parties and nobody's talked about it.
Nobody cares to talk about it. Okay. The threats of legal litigation
hasn't made anybody talk about it. I'm alleging this conspiracy
with no evidence. Okay. Except that these parties had a mutual
shared interest that they both knew about and didn't have to
coordinate over. Okay? But these people have no principles. I've
definitely never criticized anybody who alleged that the government
for came together to cause January 6th to happen. Okay? That
like there were FBI actors in the in the audience that were agitating
and caused January 6th to happen. I've never once criticized
those people. Okay? I've never once done that at all. Okay. No
request. You got to go for a while, buddy. Sorry. I don't know
why nobody's tapped you yet, but you got to you got to get out
of here. The cardinal sin of weird subreddit has been a frequent
and persistent infringer. That's how I knew when this video came
out the snarkers were going to encourage. By the way, I hope
you understand my criticism too, guys. Okay, understand that
my criticism is I do not believe you have evidence to allege
a conspiracy here. And I think that's like kind of goofy to do
so. Now, I wouldn't mind if Ethan could because of the infringement
and because of what he thinks could be a perceived link. I wouldn't
mind if he could get like uh communications between these parties
subpoena them. I don't necessarily mind that. I just think we
don't know and that's the position we should maintain is we don't
know. Right? If somebody who was involved in these communications,
if one of these mods came out and said, "Hey, I think this happened."
I wouldn't mind us alleging this and like feeling much more comfortable
saying it's likely that this happened, right? But I I've seen
nothing.
Seen nothing at all. And push streamers to commit copyright infringement.
I should thank the snarkers actually because of their predictability.
They acted like double Asians for us, incriminating their favorite
streamers and serving them up on a golden platter. So,
Central Committee. Mike from PA. Does he go by Central Committee
now? Hallucinogender
dog. Does she not realize that the channel's literally always
been called Central Committee or
Huh? Huh?
All right. I'm curious. You've You've piqu my curiosity. I wonder
if they're live.
Jesus. Okay. Out our helmet. Hey, she had those Dan Clansancy
recommendations right there. They're playing
uh you're doing what Zionists do uh do you us and just abuse
the at a plausible deniability to get around everything everyone
knows you did or had something to do with lol at Jtock. Wait,
why do you think they colluded WBY? Why do you think that there
was communication like actual direct communication between these
parties? Why do you think Denims had to collude with this party
to get most of the benefits here? Do you think most of the viewers
came from H3 Snark? Uh Lil Wubby is saying something that happens
many such cases. Okay. said by the person who engages in genocide
denial. Oh, look, it's Emory. An arc. Oh, no. An arc. It's about
whether you can make a claim and whether or not you're interrogating
that claim with any amount of intellectual honesty, right? You
can't just say, "Oh, come on. You're saying they didn't coordinate?
You're saying that? You're saying that this uh Ray Eps guy isn't
an FBI plant? Really? Why did he like Why did he agitate everybody?
Why was he out here agitating the whole day? Why was he like
getting people? Oh, we have to storm the capital tomorrow. We
have to storm the C. Why would he be doing that? It's insane.
It's for You need something. Yeah. Lil WBY. Yeah. No, you're
not doing the same thing. Lil Wby, give me a single piece of
positive evidence that shows that Denims was coordinating with
the sub. Okay. There's a lot of evidence that Epstein was an
intelligence agent. A ton of evidence. There's not the same amount
of evidence that Denims is a uh was coordinating with these people.
It's like a much it's a much more narrow accusation of behavior
that you have no no proof for. No evidence of. Anyway, I'm done
responding to you on this because you uh unless you produce positive
evidence, but you're not going to because you can't. And only
one. Wait, what? Why are they on this list?
Got one viewer. It's me.
That's mean. Katanoboa. Careful. Careful. Anyways, that guy hallucender
dog. Why is he even on this list? Do Not Worry Podcast. Let's
just I'm just curious. Do not worry podcast. I just want to commit
these names to memory. He reacted to it. He's named. Oh no. Intro.
I like the intro.
Let me tell you guys like that. Is that how it sounds? My shield.
Oh, weird. Why is it echoing? Also, it's cute. Sorry, but turn
it up cuz I'm just waiting for You can We're talking about the
uh Oh, it goes over my face. That was You're welcome, brother.
What is your What is your major malfunction?
Why is that her reaction to things like like what is happening?
She she like catches herself and realizes that there's no reason
she should be doing that in the moment and it's like oh whoops.
Oh whoops. We're talking about the uh oh it goes over my face.
That was Guys, why do you why do people her? Why do people ever
Why would they do that? It's just so disgusting how you like
her and try to denigrate her. It's so gross. It's just disgusting.
It's gross. You're welcome. Actually, you're welcome. Okay. Somebody
in my community is going to make [__] drop of that.
You're welcome. Are you again? When we get a cam, she's like
right there right now. You don't hear the echo on this guy's
stream in its entirety immediately after. See how it's a little
bit echoy. The video itself is a little bit either the thing
is there were the original video in which case I'm it's not see
it's not me. It's not me. Okay. Yeah. Basically I H3 views so
that they could watch the content nuke of fac without giving
like H3. Oh yeah. Basically uh H3 made a content nuke. A bunch
of people on Reddit like H3 Snark organized to basically intentionally
deny H3 views so that they could watch the content nuke of Hassan
without giving H3 support as you can see right here. That by
the way up thing to do. Look, I don't care how much you hate
somebody. If you really want to watch their content, give I agree
that it's aed up thing to do. The view give them the view. Like
it's crazy. Okay. Okay. especially
them intentionally cuz it's not just I think she she basically
doesn't understand the fundamental concept of people enjoying
watching someone be critiqued by somebody who knows like their
patterns and stuff. They don't understand that there's like a
like that is a different kind of content, right? There's absolutely
a different kind of content where you are like mocking something
where you are set up to watch it's like the same thing watching
like bad movies, right? It's like there is something funny about
watching that together with people and joking about it and critiquing
it. That is that is like a fundamentally different thing. What
is Destiny if not that? Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's uh that's obviously a good point. Yeah, just them
watching stuff and like denying views. That always is gonna happen
with React stuff. It's them intentionally doing it. To be fair,
that's not what Destiny does anymore. Destiny does not watch
the underlying content. He does not comment on the underlying
content. He just like lies about what other people say. It's
much easier. Listen, we all act like I I thought he didn't learn
anything from Vosch, but he did learn. Okay, he he understands
Vosch one and now he's just picking up the tactics. He's just
taking them directly. Okay, they're like explicitly coordinating
in such a way so that you can watch the content nuke and not
give him the content. Crazy. I'm tired of your notifications
not going off for me. Well, you have to spend more than $5. All
of my TTS is more than $5. Otherwise, somebody could donate one
cent and just spam us forever. Intentions couldn't be clearer.
Here's an excerpt from a sticky post from the Snark subreddit.
Hey everyone, we Okay, I'm curious though. So, this guy is one
of the people listed and we're going through them because I said
anybody on this list probably explicitly agreed with the mods
to be on this list. I'm assuming that the mod reached out. I
could be wrong if they want to come out and be like, "Earer,
you're totally wrong. I didn't know anything about this. I thought
it was wrong." Blah blah blah. That's fine. So, now I'm looking
at do not worry covering this cuz I'm very curious how he feels
about his name. Yeah, there we go. His name being on the list.
I infringement
before. How's it infringement, bro? We're reacting to your content.
someone giving someone a heads up beforehand like yo by the way
this guy's going to be reacting to this video is not copyright
infringe yeah that's what happened like guys we love Ethan we're
all going to just have a watch party that's not what happened
wait but it wasn't a watch party with denims it really wasn't
now is it a watch party by definition can you so the argument
they use is a little more subtle right the argument they use
here is that basically if she doesn't speak for more than 30
seconds it is now a group viewing session instead of a commentary
session okay and there are something like 70 such instances.
70 such instances of her like not speaking. So these are instances
where she could have cut large portions of the video out if she'd
done a pre-screening, right? That's the argument they're using.
But like by most people's definition of what react content is,
it was a reaction. Like it was an actual reaction video. It was
not like just a watch party. It was not. Now could you make this
argument in court and could this work? Possibly. Probably even,
right? But colloquially when you talk about it being a a group
viewing session, this is not what they mean. And and she did
uh was further demonstrates the overriding and dominant purpose
of Denim's group viewing session was to serve as a substitute
for the original and not to provide critical commentary. Uh I
think this is obviously untrue.
I think it's like very obviously untrue when you look at the
the actual viewership that Denim's like review of this got on
YouTube that it doesn't serve at all in any way as an actual
market replacement. Nobody who wants to who can choose between
these two things is going to watch the other, right? Nobody.
Nobody. Nobody who wants to watch just the Ethan content nuke
is gonna go, "Oh, Denims is reacting and she's making it take
four times as long." Sorry, twice as long. More than twice as
long. Oh, I would I would love that. There's not a single person
who isn't explicitly like someone who likes denims and wants
to watch Denim's opinion who's opting into that. It just it's
just not never the case. Anyway, that's not the only test, but
it's here's an excerpt from a post from the Snark subre. Hey
everyone, we've seen a lot of comments about wanting to watch
the nuke without showing support for H3. Here's a list of creators
who have supported our sub. Either by engaging with us directly
or citing our post in their critique of H3. Here they're offering
these streamers as market substitutes for my work. This is the
cardinal sin of copyright infringement. The snark subreddit has
been a frequent and persistent infringeer. That's how I knew
when this video came out. The snarkers were going to encourage,
promote, and push streamers to commit copyright infringement.
I should think what why did I click play on this? God, I I literally
I just listen. I stroked out there. I forgot we were watching
Aerodite. Oh, I thought I like hit play and I heard Ethan's voice
and we were watching Ethan's thing and the screen was just up
on the Milhouse guys stream. So, I uh I I I choked out there.
Okay. Also, watch parties annoying for streamers, okay? Every
now and then, people in my server will be like, "We're going
to have a watch party for your content." And I'm like, "Don't
just go watch it. It's better than nothing." But they're he's
acting like all they did is coordinate little cute cute little
watch parties for the H3 content. They explicitly list in there
that they are doing it to deny H3 revenue, which is crazy. Okay.
How did it intentions couldn't be clearer? Here's an excerpt
from a sticky post from the Snark subreddit. Hey everyone, we've
seen a lot of comments about wanting to watch the new All right,
I want to see his reaction. Actually, because of their predictability,
they acted like double Asians for us, incriminating their favorite
streamers and serving them up on a golden platter. So, yo, I'm
in good company. I'm judge me by my enemies and judge me by my
friends. I think I'm a pretty good company. We will. We will.
We are. Yeah. Hold on. Waited the hell. Okay, I see. Hold on.
Hold on. I was just trying to find Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Where's Okay, I was just going to pull up the video
of her talking about she's going back on tour with Destiny. Okay,
that's all I was going to do. That's what I was going to do.
Me and my friends, well
are horrible. Like imagine how he would feel if anyone who hated
denims the way that they hate Ethan coordinated like Denim's
releasing new content, not streamed content, just like content
by itself and everyone coordinated together, a bunch of people
that Ethan Klein coordinated. Don't watch Denim's content. Just
wait. You can watch it here on my channel. So you can deny Denim's
money. They Yeah, it would be really I don't think Denim should
necessarily sue on that, but it would be really would be they
would be up in arms. Crazy. This is why, by the way, I'm so glad
that a lot of this is going to like actual judges and courts
because the internet has become so stupid when it comes to like
this. They'll be like, "Yeah, but I like feel like it's fine
because I do it to people that I really hate." And the court
of law is going to be like, "That's not how this works. That
doesn't make it okay." Right now, folks, hey,
is this enough reacting for you, Ethan? Am I pausing enough and
giving enough context? Are you going to sue me for this? Jesus
Christ. It's one thing. By the way, Ethan addresses that for
a subreddit to admit it's engaging and copyright infringement,
but how do you get the streamers themselves to admit
financial gain? People like XQC and Asold may have watched the
entire thing, but I would never sue them just for doing that.
I don't want to chill the reaction community into fear. Actually,
the opposite. I hope that we can all unite against this type
of egregious behavior. Oh, what is she going to say to this?
So, why are you okay? Why are you suing Dennis? You don't want
to sue XQC and Asmin Gold? Why not? We know they're your new
friend. Just in case you're wondering, Ethan also explains that.
Wait, what is his reaction going to be when they answer that?
Cuz he goes into why specifically Denims and Froggen. Their audience
is not the only ones who left this. But what the [__]
is the But hold on. The the the unfortunate issue for people
who have any amount of understanding of what's going on here
is
that Denims will do more to chill reaction content than suing
XQC could. Okay. suing Denims, the the ruling there is far more
likely to chill reaction content than anything they could rule
on denims. So when he says, "Oh, I'm not doing this to chill
reaction cont." That's just a lie. This is a lie cuz he doesn't
want those people on his ass. Good point. All of that but could
destroy the commentary community as we know it. Well, guys, uh
if you enjoyed um not giving any views to that terrible video,
follow, subscribe, throw a prime. Why is it theft, though? I
mean, okay, if someone doesn't comment at all and they're just
literally re-watching a video on stream, sure, an argument can
be made that is content theft. There needs to be the reaction
needs to be transformative, right? I agree. Uh, but I mean I
haven't seen Den's reaction to me. So I don't really know what
she did. But like to call this Ethan does Ethan reacts to videos
until there's That's a bad statement. I don't know why. Why would
you say I got no idea what Denim's reaction was. I've not seen
any characterization of it. I've not seen the entire thing. I've
not seen any clips of it, but I'm pretty sure it was transformative.
For the record, I have not watched Denim's thing either, but
I've read the content, sorry, the actual lawsuits description
of her stuff, and from that I can put together that it's far
more transformative than like most of the most at least far more
transformative than Felix's reaction. Right. Right. I've not
seen like a significant portion of this, but basically in here
they say, oh, here like here, you know, if you take the anti-
timestamps, this is all of her pausing and stuff. All of her
pausing to speak. And they have a bunch of her exact um what
do you call it? quotes from her and why she's like misleading
or misinforming or not giving good commentary, right? Like their
primary their first number one complaint was of her commentary
was that it was bad. It was wrong. It was misinforming. It was
it was not good. That was like their primary argument. Wasn't
that she didn't do it. Wasn't that she did a group viewing session
for the content nuke, right? That wasn't um Oh, sorry. It wasn't
that uh she didn't comment at all, right? Or that her comment
commentary was like, "Yeah, like Hutch suggested not speaking
for 90 minutes." It was literally that. Oh, her her she's lying.
She's lying when she actually criticizes here. Anyway, we continue.
We continue. Of reaction of reacts. Yes. He's not saying that
just reacting is bad. Twitch doesn't even have any copyright.
If you're reacting to stuff on YouTube, your video get taken
down. Twitch doesn't give a [__] Uh, Dreadmaster.
No, that's wrong. That's just completely wrong. You are completely
wrong. But it's okay. You can be completely wrong. Uh, malicious
intent when creating a market replacement. with regards to the
market replacement pillar of fair use. Malicious intent has no
effect except potentially on damages or it's obviously proof
of willful intent, right? Malicious intent is a higher bar than
willful intent. You can't be you can't be malicious and non-willful.
So obviously it also proves that the willful intent for the statutory
damages. But in terms of finding out if she copyright she infringed
on his copyright, it will not be relevant. Content on Twitch
is exactly um members go out or get we can all sue him for that.
I can sue Ethan for reacting to my podcast on a show. That's
just like made up. It's a madeup idea people have. and these
creators get comfortable. He's so mad. He's so mad. This is where
it's really valuable. By the way, some people pre pre-watch their
React content. In fact, I suspect probably some of the top React
content creators
explicitly do that and probably have a couple bullet points of
scripts made. I'm like 90% sure that this is happening, which
in and of itself, I actually don't even care that much because
I don't care if somebody reacts, but they take like 10 minutes
to write out what they think will be the most interesting things
to say. as long as it's all things that they genuinely believe
as well. I don't actually care if you like pre-watch and prepare
some of the things that you think are better to say. I don't
need to just see your like knee-jerk emotional vomit all the
time. Sometimes it's interesting. Some people cook. Okay. Some
people are cookers with their emotional vomit. Have I ever done
it? I have not. Not yet. Maybe I should. Maybe I should. She
means Chud was a square shot. Really? I think I don't think Chud
pre-watches, but I think Chud
I think Chud usually has a good idea of like the discussion that's
going around on around content without having watched the content
itself, which I think is totally fine to do. It's not like an
accusation that he's like pre-watching. He's like figured out
exactly what jokes to make or something. I do think that he normally
samples like he he goes on Twitter and he said this explicitly.
I'll go on Twitter and I'll check out like some of the the discussion
around it before I actually watch it, right? I think that's fairly
normal. I think a lot of people do that. So, you know, it is
what it is. It's kind of smart as word. Uh oh, I just got linked
a clip. Okay, I just got linked a clip. Oh no. Oh no. I just
got linked a clip. Critical pisco straight raid reaction to something.
They were watching a podcast earlier. Uh the title of the clip
implies some sort of racism. I really hope not. Papa gut live.
Papa Gut live. I'm going to move Papa Gut or remove Papa Gut.
What? Yo, what up Chris? We can't see you, but we might be able
to hear you. Hey,
no.
It's the guy. It's the guy. It's the guy who's always racist
and trolling. He's in their Discord.
Me? Yeah. You're like, "Are you Chris?" Yes. Hey, you're in like
a construction zone. Yeah.
This guy's trolling.
What' you say? So,
Aaron, can you hear me? Is Aaron here? Yeah. Yes, I am. What
am I lying about? Please tell your blood of anger about stream.
So, after
QCer
All right, you're done. That was a I told you. I told you. You
just You just rewarded bad behavior because all you did was bring
it to me. It's a pretty good meme though. Pretty good meme. Never
gets old. Never gets old. Yeah, it doesn't It doesn't get old.
Okay.
H It's like so annoying. You want people to like actually talk
to you, dude. All right, you're done. That was a I told you.
I [__] told you. You just you just rewarded bad behavior
because all you did was bring it to me.
It's a pretty good meme though.
Pisco's like Pisco knows that he can't do that accent himself.
He wants to. He desperately wants to. He knows he can't do it
himself. Okay. So, he drags that guy in and he lives vicariously
through him for a few seconds. Okay. That 60 seconds that he
gets to live vicariously through that guy who can do like a racist
accent. All right. He loves it. He loves it. The straight raid
stream of Pisco now. Straight raid streams. I think part of her
Pisco shows up for like parts of her stream. I think um yeah,
they just react to I think they react to like I I've seen her
take. They react to her take together. I think Pisco just uh
he likes streaming a lot now. Oh, whoops. We're done here. We're
done here. We're done here. All right. Back to Aerodites. What
if you're completely wrong? Well, this is the tough thing with
React content is you have to be on the ball otherwise you get
caught with your pants down like this guy who's being like, "Well,
what's special? Is straighter raid still in DGG?" No. Uh, in
fact, uh, a lot of DJers are suggesting that Strider is the reason
Pisco is now a quote unquote communist who only acts in spite
of destiny. Yeah, DJers are now like actually full on full on
complete. All right. I think Pisco just doesn't hate Straighter
and Lykan. Um, if you know anything behind the scenes, I don't
think like it was treated like super well on his way out of like
Miami. I think it kind of I don't think Lykan complained about
it. Lykan kept all that to himself. It's just if you know some
of the stories there, uh, if you remember, we're watching the
anything else clip last night and Dan wanted to leak some stuff.
I think Lykan was not treated particularly well on his way out.
Okay, what's the T? I'm not talking about it cuz I don't know
I don't even know where I heard these stories from and I don't
want to like I don't want to have to cite these things. I just
think uh I just think he was not treated well. You don't even
have to know much about it to know he wasn't treated well. They
treated him like for the last couple days of the podcast, last
couple podcasts, and then when he when he was actually let go,
that was like a weird stream, right? that they gave him a job
and like on him and on like all of his contributions and then
like kicked him off, right? Oh, right. And there was the Israel
Palestine stuff going on. Yeah. Yeah. It was just Yeah. He just
was not treated well on the way out. Um Yeah. So, I think um
and I think like Pisco obviously must have some sympathies around
the Israel Palestine stuff. He doesn't like he doesn't get fully
into it, but I do not believe he is like a you know he is not
as pro
he's not as pro- Israel as a lot of the people around him. Um,
obviously Joanne is super pro Palestine, right? So I would imagine
he's got some fairly nuanced takes there and I that he was just
friends with Lykan in straight raid. Hisco is not zogged. Uh,
no, I don't believe so. Anyway, um, we we continue on here. Oh
yeah, the whole thing was straight's not DG. Destiny like actively
kind of talks them now. So
about them, it's like if you just like wait 3 seconds, it will
be explained in the video. But also for it to be transformative,
you need to comment every like 30 to 40 seconds. So got to be
careful. It's a it's a tough balance truly to strike. Looking
right into a camera and saying outright, "Hey, I'm stealing this
guy's content." Guys, I don't like I don't pre-screen any of
my reactions at all. Not even a little bit. Description
notepad. Hey, I'm not saying that's proof of anything, okay?
That could be a description of something totally different. I
just wonder why it's highlighted at this exact moment in time.
I just wonder why she most over it. I that's all. Pay me instead
of him. This is not a healthy environment. And with people like
Assan reacting to entire TV shows on stream, my fear is that
Sony or maybe Hold on. Maybe that was just the video. Right into
a camera. Was it just the video? No, it was definitely her mousing
over it on her desk. I'm stealing this guy's content. Pay me
instead of him. This is not a healthy environment. And with people
like Hassan reacting to entire TV shows on stream. My fear is
that Sony or Disney comes along. Oh my god. I just can't see
her actually being on a script. Okay, I can't see it. I don't
think so. Destiny just banned Lykan and Aaron and said they're
good people. Now you should talk to them for what reason? Pathetic.
uh because he believes that he he believes that they totally
flipped their politics because of
destiny because like of in spite of destiny and like we don't
at all remember that literally Lyken was being harassed for having
his positions like long before he left. Aaron did sell him to
Sunday. I don't interpret it that way and I don't think he interpreted
it that way. Unfortunately, if you It's tough because like I
totally understand why why Pixie can't be friends with Aaron.
Like the trust violation there, but I truly in my hearts heart
of hearts after talking to Aaron feel like that was just somebody
she was very close to and she felt like she didn't think she
would get betrayed there. I think she had like some people she
was close to and she felt like there's just these people are
trustworthy and maybe they weren't quite as trustworthy as she
thought. That's my that's my personal opinion. That's how I look
at it. I don't need other people to share that opinion. God.
Oh my god, ETH. He wants to ruin streaming for everyone, bro.
Now, if I can't watch entire TV shows with my chat and make money
while doing so, he's ruined streaming. It's the end of the entire
industry. Denim's react will have like substantial if that goes
to a decision. I believe that will have substantial downstream
effects. I believe that will actually change
possibly like a lot of streaming. Okay. And it's not about her
reacting to the whole thing without commentary. It's not about
just black partying it because that's not what's even that's
not what happened. If I can't watch a entire TV series,
it's crazy. It's crazy. Okay, he wants to get the attention of
S. Hey, Sony. Hey, Disney. Hey, Dan Sultman. Make sure your audience
sends an email writing. He starts an email writing camp. Dan
Saltman,
name drop friend of the stream, Dan. Dan the content man.
Disney. Wait, hold on. Is it harassment to do an email campaign
to target the sponsors of somebody who you don't like? Is that
harassment? If people had gone after Ethan's sponsors, would
would we have considered that harassment in some way? Hey, I
don't like that this guy talked about Never mind. Never mind.
Never mind. It's like no nothing. Was it cool? Was it Was it
cool when Dan docks that guy for like calling him a Diddy en
or did accusing him of taking money from Diddy on Twitter? Was
it cool when Dan posted that picture of that guy underage kissing
another underage person? Was that cool when Dan did that? Really
weird response to Diddy allegations. By the way, here's a picture
of you and another friend in high school kissing.
I forgot that that happened until I started talking about this.
Sony, let them know what what creators like Hassan and Froggen
are doing. We need to change the YouTube rules and laws. That's
what he wants. He just wants to ruin the platform for everyone.
That's what Ethan wants to do. He just wants to everyone in the
app. Hey Disney, he tried with the sponsors last time. He started
lifting the sponsors of the of the uh of the hummus tier list.
No one gave a now he's going for Disney and Sony. Let's see if
that works. Hey Bob Iger. Hey Bob. I don't know what this argument
is from this guy. Bob Iger. You You know, Hassan that everybody
and sets a devastating they're going to ruin it by letting people
know what's going on in the in the streaming space. That's probably
not okay. Uh they had the same political views for like a year
before. The constant lying on people's views because he stopped
interacting with them is is sad. Pisco still says him and Destiny
are closely aligned politically just before Destiny banned him
on Twitter. Yeah, I'm aware. I'm aware. I'm aware. That could
endanger our entire field. Just so it's clear. I don't know if
this isn't clear enough. I am opposed to people just reacting
to entire TV shows. I don't think that that's super good. Don't
think that's the best uh best fair use policy to have. Okay.
I think most people are opposed to to taking works from latigious
like owners and doing this. The issue with Ethan is he participates
in a culture where this is like broadly accepted. And he was
broadly accepting of this culture of people watching full videos
so long as they reacted like you know in this quote unquote ethical
way where they cite the creator, right? He was broadly okay with
that kind of reaction. That's the issue, right? And he had he
is engaging in litigation that potentially threatens that kind
of reaction. That is the problem, right? That's that's where
the criticism comes in. He's crashing out. He's not crashing
out. He's just mad. Now, before I tell you who the your entire
field of streaming, which you already which you do, you react
to videos, Ethan. Oh my god, bro. Shid. He want He doesn't want
anyone else to enjoy what he does. He got suess out of reacting
to people's videos. He doesn't want to allow you to become successful
by reacting to people's videos. So, he know you get what he's
doing right now. If he wants to take it away from everyone, that's
it. Because people are reacting to his footage. And And Ethan
Ethan wants to take it away from me. Calling him out for being
a Did he say the hummus or homop? He said hummus. Uh,
we'll see if this goes anywhere else, but I think we're we're
getting close to the end of what we're going to watch here. Panel
that happened. I kind of want to watch mostly the stream of the
video. Doesn't want anyone to be allowed to react to anything
anymore. Listen, if you reacted to me, you called me an idiot.
If no one reacts, anything happens. Oh, hold on. Also, I'm not
watching the timer. Where's the timer at? Timer's at 25 minutes,
guys. And we are what, five? No, no, no, no, no, no, no. We are
eight subs away from two more hours in the stream. Is that right?
Yeah, eight subs away from two more hours of the stream. If you
guys want to do that, guys, there's the Kickbot donations. There's
Streamlabs. Stream I think Kickbot is is linked in the kick chat.
All right. You can give subs on Kick. You could sub with Twitch
Prime. Okay, you can do a bunch of different stuff. Let's say
seven subs and we'll take some of the Twitch primers from earlier
tonight. We'll roll them into uh into donos. Okay, so seven subs,
two more hours in the stream. I believe in you guys. I think
you can make it happen. You got two more hours in you. Yeah,
I do. Yeah, I'm not even tired right now to be honest with you.
Not tired at all. That's what we do now. My lawyers. I bring
my lawyers right now. Yeah, that's his position. Even though
he just said, "Look, I'm not opposed to people reacting to content.
In fact, I'm not targeting most people who reacted to my content
in full. Three people I'm suing are. I just want to make it clear
that they all met this very specific high bar of criteria that
I set forth earlier. These people were not targeted based on
their gender, their identity, their political beliefs. All three
are on this list. In fact, they're the only three as far as I
could tell that reacted to the full video. By the way, if he
did target them based on their gender or political beliefs or
whatever, I don't know that we would have criticism for that.
I don't know that we as long as he was just honest about like
what he was doing. I don't know if like people would have criticism,
but like he can choose to sue whoever he wants, right? He could
sue only the black people who reacted to this. He could do that
if he wanted to. It'd be weird. I don't think he would want to.
But ultimately, you can sue whoever infringes on your copyright.
You can pick and choose. Just don't say that you don't want to
chill React content and pick a case that you're going to sue
where you will clearly chill React content if you're successful.
Drum roll, please. Who's sweating at home, guys? Casey Tron,
the queen of ripping farts and bongo. They do musicals. They're
very musical people. He's actually suing this person, dog. What?
Look, you think I Frogan who? Bless her soul. He's suing Frogan.
Can you swing Casey drawn? Bro, she's still rising. Can I use
Can I walk away and use the bathroom? Do I have permission? Okay.
Um Oh, two minutes over. I don't know how much more we're going to
do with this. Man, leftists love the line. Uh if we if we don't
get to one of the goals, one of the stream goals for more time
on the stream. I do believe
maybe I could just maybe I could stretch this out. Okay, I think
we could stretch this out just a little bit longer. Get more
stuff going here. Uh maybe think about doing an oil call. I'm
trying to think of content I could have for an oiler call. I
don't think I want to do pirate software in order to call. Probably
going to save that for stream. Although maybe I'm never going
to do it. We'll see. We'll see. I'll try to think of it. But
they don't love this line when it's used against them. Very interesting.
He also said what he wanted was for corporate legal teams not
to crack it down on streamers. I believe the standards were they
reacted in full. They were not transformative and they did it
maliciously to like harm Ethan Klein. I think he all three of
these things. And so he's caught all three people. I could be
wrong about the three. That's what I think I remember the three
standards being. I just I wonder why nobody like bothered to
read what the accusation was that it was like not transformative
like in terms of what we think transformation is right what we
would broadly expect like yeah the primary issue I'll say one
last time okay and then I don't think I'm going to say this again
for the rest of the night the primary issue with suing Denims
over the content nuke is that within like the current culture
she is adding substantial commentary she is doing like a political
critique right she is doing this stuff she makes quite a few
points points during her reaction to the video within the current
culture that is like a substantial reaction. Okay, which means
that most reactors do something somewhat similar to her. Okay,
if you make the court answer the question of whether or not she
transformed, I think it's 9010ish
that she didn't transform. Okay, because of the because she could
have done more work to make sure that she wasn't using uh commentary
or wasn't using parts of the video that she wasn't transforming
that she didn't have commentary for. She could have done some
pre-work for that. And because she didn't, I think it can't be
ruled fair use. And because it can't be ruled fair use, we're
going to get a whole bunch of people who stream and do this,
I think we're basically going to get a precedent. This seems
like the most likely thing to me where this idea of streaming
without having vetted the video that will disappear, right? I
think that is the most likely case. That is the precedent we
fear happening. We don't want it to happen. Um, having it open
the way it is now allows a lot more free flowing commentary,
a lot more back and forth of ideas, actual criticism, right?
And if none of that happens, uh, if none of that can happen,
then I I worry about like the state of online criticism of like
political critique of all this because I don't know why given
the the the political nature of these videos, I don't know why
uh actual political people online wouldn't be like uh wouldn't
be protected by the same thing, right? So, if you are doing a
full reaction to like Tucker Carlson's interview with Vladimir
Putin, does Tucker Carlson not have the ability to like sue you,
take you to uh to uh copyright jail, whatever the So, there'
just be a bunch of like actual political commentary that I think
society broadly benefits from people being able to comment on
that wouldn't really be open to commentary in the same way, I
think. But, we'll see. We'll see. That feels like concerning
to me. I think it's good where it is. I think that's best for
society. I just don't know if it's actually illegal. I think
it's probably not actually uh like legal for for the thing the
way React content works currently. Anyway, that's my final final
point there. My concern it's malicious. It's aimed to deny H3
money. Um
what was the last one? Oh, it's not transformative enough. I'll
leave it playing. I think I saw a clip earlier where you said
if she had pulled up resources back check during the stream,
it would have adhered to fair use standards. Am I remembering
that correctly? Uh no, I believe she did do that. I thought she
literally pulled some clips and was like trying to show context
for things. I believe she did that already. So, I don't think
I I don't think I would have been the person to say that, but
Oh, that's insane. Oh, Cherry's not good. Oh, no. She went to
the bathroom, folks. She went to the bathroom. You know, that
means litigation time. He's just not trying. He just doesn't
want to know. And openly stated they were intentionally malicious.
Yes. All three of them were like, "Give me money if you like
explicitly denying H3." Again, replace this with any content
creator who's like any other sides. If you explicitly enjoy denying
Kamal money, watch me here. We'll watch his entire content so
that you don't have to give him any of your view dollars. It's
just like and then the reaction to it, by the way, is do do we
think that that guarantees like I would just say what what makes
Eerite think that let's say let's say Eerite and Queen in a vacuum.
Okay. What makes Eerite think that anybody watching Queen's content
would go to her channel and give her money? I actually don't
know. Like they are there. They are fans of Queenman's reactions
to his visceral reactions to not so erodite. That is what they
are fans of. That's why they would watch that content, right?
I just I don't understand how we're doing this thing. Um I and
I gave this example with uh let's do a different one. Destiny
watching a Trump thing. What makes you think that, you know,
a One America News Network broadcast of like some Trump speech
that a bunch of people from DGG want to watch that in a vacuum
and don't really just want to watch Desi's reaction to that Trump
speech? what makes her think that it's not the the content creator
that they're there for, right? Or like the criticality of the
content creator. Like I would say probably on a lot of days if
there's a big day where Hassan was off and Hassan was directing
all of his audience to go watch Denims that like she could get,
you know, maybe not quite the numbers she got for the content
nuke, right? But she get pretty high numbers too. But that the
Denims thing you can also kind of make this argument for because
of the huge increase in in viewership. I don't know where people
get like a similar massive bounce in viewership because they're
like, "Oh, let's uh let's not give any views to Arrodite, right?"
I don't know why she's including herself in this. I've definitely
seen hate dono/TS, though. I have as well. Yeah, I have as well,
but I just I don't know why we think um Yeah, I just don't know
why we think it would work the same way or that like there's
somehow like major damage is being suffered because
people are hate watching her content somewhere. Again, I think
most of my commentary here has been fairly fair. Fairly fair.
pretty fair. Passing fair. I don't think I'm like I'm not sitting
here talking about how she's like uh
how she's like a grease ball or some [__] like what
other people do. Okay, I'm not the person saying how like disgusting
I find someone's appearance. I don't like that kind of commentary
because I'm a nice person. Okay, I'm a very nice person. That's
like why I don't watch Destiny's content. It's because I wouldn't
be able to hold my tongue and I'm a nice person. I'm just commenting
on her ideas. Okay, that's it. I got to pee and then yeing out
of there. Actually, it would be more transformative if she yed
it out of there. Then you could get like a memeable moment at
least. Oh, uh, Cbassess,
thank you for the gifted sub to Meowzilla Killer. Thank you.
Thank you. Interviewing a Ye teenager who's only And Denim's
the queen of self owning. And my god, is she the queen of that.
It's very obvious from the way that guy's talking. He's a Sneo
fan. Oh my god. Well, I love you. This has been [__]
disproven multiple times. Even Ethan. Hassan talked about this
to Ethan face to face in the [__] debate. The guy
was clearly not a [__] Hassan fan. He's now calling
Hassan an F-word, bro. He hates Hassan. He's now pro Ethan. Oh
my god. But this is so bad faith. Ethan, you can make your video.
Throw it to super people to at least use updated information
that we all know you're familiar with. Bro, come on, man. Let's
just be clear, and this is something I don't like about Ethan.
This guy's been a petty [__] from the very beginning.
You guys just liked it when he did it to Pearl. He was bad faith
as [__] to Pearl multiple times. He was super bad
faith to Myron Gaines. He was super bad faith. That girl that
he brought on to like talk about like all the crazy Oh, I forgot
about that one. I forgot about how he like tried to basically
make make this woman like call Myron Gains a I forgot about that
of like Myin like pressuring her and stuff like that. Super bad
faith. Didn't fact check any of it. He was super bad faith to
Abam preach. He's a petty mother. Oh, he also doxed a random
Nick Lee that wasn't Nick Lee,
didn't he? He doxed like a guy who was not Nick. He tried to
dox Nick over the Amaran stuff and he docked some random dude
named Nick Lee. Not actually Nick Lee, right? Am I crazy on that
one? Yeah. It's almost like he's a total degenerate piece of
who is like a bully. He's just a loser. Crazy.
Friend of the stream, Nick. Yes. Friend of the stream, Nick.
And always has been. And I I'm so tired of people. A I'm tired.
It's like that's not like pettiness. Trying to make this woman
uh accuse minor games of is not really pettiness. It's like being
a total scumbag. It's like morally totally I was I I keep wanting
to say morally black. I'm gonna keep with the black and white
analogies, okay? It's not racism. It's just easy. All right.
It's like totally morally black. There's like no moral there's
no like moral neutrality there at all. He's just like trying
to pressure this woman into calling uh Marian Gains a so bizarre
to people like dustling Ethan Klein and pretending like that
hasn't always kind of been true. But also, you guys liked it
when he did it to your enemies.
So, at least get consistent. At least when he was being a petty
to Myron Gains, I was like, "Yeah, I mean this is not Yeah, I
didn't like that. I I'm pretty sure I called out I'm pretty confident
I called out I remember getting anger from people for defending
Myron in the conversation with Ethan the the later conversation
they had.
Okay. In this case, if this has been disproven, which I wouldn't
be surprised when the guy comes up and says like, "Yo, Hassan,
you're my I'm your biggest fan. I wouldn't be surprised if that
was like a red pill guy like trying to clip bait Hassan." Oh,
right. Me at all. Yeah. Ethan lies a lot with you. Like it's
so weird where it was just like, "Yeah, I know that Ethan lies.
I know that Ethan like totally lies to smear anybody he perceives
as his enemy and that he has no morals whatsoever. I know that
he's demonstrated that again and again and again and again and
again and again and again and again and again and again and again
and again and again and again that he has no morals. He is a
completely he's just a complete is a complete oh what is the
word that I would want to use like insecure
bully. Insecure bully I'm just going to say okay I want I thought
of a whole bunch of other like really mean things to say but
just insecure bully. He is just always trying to bully somebody.
He's always trying to make himself bigger than somebody else.
And it's weird. Okay, that thing he did, that thing he did when
he's on vacation. He's like, "Hey, Taylor Loren, I want you to
apologize. Apologize to me. And maybe I won't sue one of your
friends. I'm going to sue him unless you apologize
to me." When he did that, like that's who he is at his essence.
That's Ethan Klein in a nutshell right there, right? He goes,
"Oh, actually, I I didn't actually want to sue them." No, I didn't
actually want to I didn't want to sue them. He's like just a
just a gross weirdo. Okay, that's who he is. He's a bully. He's
a gross weird bully that tries to use his platform to like I
don't know just go after anybody who's like against him. Like
he he just makes enemies and goes after them. It's like like
a pattern. And he has no he's not concerned about telling the
truth. He's not concerned about any anything close to being like
good faith to anybody. He is a mean-spirited
lying bully who nobody should look up to and nobody should defend.
In fact, no, I'm not going to go that far yet. He was a fan,
but then it turned out if he turned out that he didn't, whatever.
I believe that. Uh, it's just like, yeah, welcome to Ethan Klein.
He's always been a bit of a petty [__] Like, what?
By the way, he literally had a viewer call in to accuse his sister-in-law
of making up her childhood.
What? What? Oh, well, that would be a good one to bring up. Huh.
I hope somebody's writing these down. Like I hope somebody's
working on just like a good video that basically like like Ryan
Beard for example. I know Ryan Beard did a great job on that
Destiny content nuke. Okay, he did a fantastic job. Why couldn't
he just make an Ethan video? Why couldn't he just sack up and
make a sack up and make an Ethan video? Do it. Do it. Do it.
Isn't his sister-in-law Trisha? I'm guessing it was Trisha. Yeah,
it would have to be Trisha Pis, right? He's suing three women.
Two out of the three are Arab. Coincidence? Two out of the three
people he's suing are Arab women and three out of three are women.
Insane. Coincidence?
Coincidence that it was these three women? That's such lazy analysis.
And I'm almost positive Ethan sued these women only to uh to
just give people like that thing to latch on to. It's just it's
like lazy. I don't care about it. Okay. If he'd only sued black
people, I wouldn't care. I just I don't care. Met the very high
caliber. I got Bro, bro, he even predicted by saying it's not
because of any like race created gender. He Ethan said that because
he knew people are just going to be like, "You just hate women."
And it's like, "No." Why did Ethan stop the Hassan video? He
stopped it because
he was, sorry, not Ethan. Why did uh why did I say that? Why
did Ryan Beard stop the Ethan Hassan video? He stopped it because
he thought it was not going to make an impact, that nobody would
care either way, that people were too ideologically bought in
on both sides and there's no like upside to making it. Basically
only loses by making it, which probably is true. That sucks to
say.
Need somebody who's more idealistic. Okay. Somebody who's principled.
You need somebody who will sacrifice financially for the for
to do the right thing. Okay, that's what you need. You need somebody
who doesn't care about money, who isn't motivated by money, who
is motivated by, hey, I see an injustice. I see somebody doing
something wrong in the world. You need Okay, you need YouTube
Batman. Where is YouTube Batman? Where is he? Where is the guy
who will who will give up everything to follow his principles,
okay? Doesn't need the money, doesn't need the thanks. He will
just be there. Where is he? No,
I love you both. None of the hostages that have been released
so far have said that they have been the hostages have public
statements. You can go look at them. This assault I experienced
should never happen to any human being. This Yemen kid is just
a Yemen with a gun in his literally suing her because she said
things he disagrees with. He's putting No,
no. Oh no. That's your takeaway of her saying things that he
doesn't agree with. You can't sue someone for disagreeing with
them. Ethan, either she stole your content by watch Here's the
crazy thing. If that's all the lawsuit was, none of this would
matter. It wouldn't be a threat because the courts
that is what the content nuke thing is and it would be a threat
if that that is like that is quite literally like the precedent
this will set right or sorry the president this could set this
pre the president this could set there could they could go you
know what we're really compelled by this argument that if you're
just like wrong that that's not substantial commentary and so
many listen that would be a but it would get rid of a lot of
people that I don't like first so man I don't even know if that's
the worst. I think it's bad, but I don't want that bar because
I think it it probably swings in a way I can't expect back towards
me, but I I don't know. It might not be the worst thing in the
world. Maybe maybe that was probably the worst. Sorry, I'm going
back and forth in my head. Would agree with that. They'd be like,
"Oh, she just disagrees with you, Ethan. You can't sue them."
If that's actually what was going on. Like, do you think that
he would pay a law firm to take this on and pay like all the
money? Maybe. Maybe he's p enough petty enough that he would.
But if you genuinely think that his position is that I'm suing
them because I don't like them essentially and I want to try
to get him, I wouldn't really worry about it because the courts
aren't going to hold that up like at all. Oh
boy. I wish this had a better arm. It's so bad. Look at it. Just
sinks. It just sinks. I think that's part of the reason though.
And I think that's a reason to sue probably. So sucks
without providing any context, without reacting to it, which
I highly doubt someone like Venoms would do. He's literally just
showing clips of why he doesn't like denims. Literally. Oh, look.
She denied the Oh, look. She said this about this person. That's
why you want to [__] sue him. That's why you want
to [__] sue him. Remember when I said, "I don't think
Denim should raise money so that she can sue Ethan." Denim, you
have all of my support. If Ethan actually sues you, we will try.
We will help every creator that is being sued by Ethan raise
money for their lawsuits. I promise you that. I I said I'm not
for All you're going to do is that if he has a legitimate lawsuit,
he will just be able to claim a lot of that money. You're just
going to potentially pay him uh how much for a new arm? I I think
probably those aren't going to be damages in any way. Uh it will
be go to him, but it will prevent those people from being bankrupted
probably. Uh honestly, I'll probably need like the really expensive
one cuz I move it so often. Raising money to sue. So like one
101 120 probably, Ethan, but if Ethan is going to sue anyone,
I'm going to help in any way that I can these people raise money
for their defense lawsuits. [__] way we're going
to let that happen. It's just going to come for the money you
raised then, too. 5 minutes left, guys. Uh we are six six subs
away from 2 hours. Okay. Uh I think we'll just we'll finish off
with Aerodite here if that's where we're going to end in 5 minutes
and I'll probably go I'm going to grab some food after this and
go to do like an oiler call probably. We'll see what we got for
it. I'll see what we got. We'll check it out. Oh god. By the
way, I got everyone's back and whichever small way I can help,
I'm going to try to help. Bro, his reaction as I have watched
the H3 like the original I've watched this full thing. It is
crazy. I but I've never watched this guy's reaction before. I
I don't even know who this person is. It is crazy how much their
reaction is exactly what he predicted it would be. Oh boy.
This is truly Do you guys remember when Britney Venty annihilated
Rolo Tamasi with her like long con?
That's another one where it's like, wait, you just you just like
emailed this poor schizophrenic old man and lied to him a lot.
Like a lot a lot. you just like made up a whole bunch of to lie
to him and then you're like w us we totally lied to this guy.
We totally like made up a conspiracy and like uh and totally
fooled this guy. It's not that it's not funny. It's just like
dude that is a level of like scop that I I I think very few people
would invest in. That's something that like only the most unhinged
of hate. Listen, if H3 if H3 Snark did that to Ethan Klein, I
just want people to think about how that would be received, okay?
If they just if they started messaging Ethan Klein were like,
"Hey, I'm like Hassan's like I'm like Hassan's, you know, stepsister
and he assaulted me and they start like sending documents to
this guy to prove who they are and it's like Hassan's in on it
and they just totally entrap this guy into like making an accusation.
I feel like wouldn't that just be weird? Aren't you just like
isn't that like odd? I thought that was just a Lauren Southern
coverup. Uh was it? I don't think so. I think there were some
other things there where they were like pretending Oh, are they
pretending that like she got pregnant by Destiny or some it was
like it was weird, but it's like Lauren Southern just using her
own sending her own details to uh Rolo to make him believe it.
You should fact check if you're going to break news. I think
you should fact check. But what was getting fact? I think these
were like facts about Lauren's life that were real that you could
like check in on and but I I I don't remember for sure. Maybe
there was I'm guessing there was a way he could have like done
some basic work and figured it out, right? I still think it's
like weird. I think it's I think it's weird. I just think it's
very weird. Control personally um where she was like sending
him emails and stuff. This is it's not quite that tier because
that was
chef's kiss. Okay, that was a long con. I remember when Jtock
thought that was a good thing. No, you don't. I have the same
opinion as I had back then. I literally was like, isn't this
kind of weird to just like set this up? I actually Longhawk,
it's so funny that you say that because I believe I was given
I was given some stuff around Rolo where something similar happened
and I didn't even report on it because I was like, "Oh, this
is weird. This feels like um this feels like something like we're
just trying to we're trying to like break a story on this guy
when I I can't really confirm it." I I remember this happening.
That's very very funny that you come here and just like actually
make things up and have no idea what you're talking about. Welcome
though. Welcome. I don't remember a time where you haven't come
to chat and said, "How long has it been?" Uh,
oh yeah, what was this? Um, what will you Oh, you were here defending
Destiny a couple weeks back. Let's see here. Basically, nothing
else. Know their comments. Why does Jtock boost the numbers of
a website that is used to funnel people into a gambling site
where many people will ruin their lives? Cuz I get money for
it and I just like streaming. Anyway, we're good. We can move
on. This is pretty damn close. Like, this is John Oliver tier
trolling. Okay, I like this. Doesn't this guy usually have two
sidekicks? I don't know. I've literally never seen Do Not Worry
podcast. Never heard of it. He's got a really cool intro, though.
The little like dudead song that he I actually don't know of
anybody who's like who watches my stream who's ever gone to uh
Gamble on stake. I would love to know if somebody's gone to gamble
on stake at the beginning. Where is it? Be interesting to me.
Oh my gosh. For you just freaked out. Oh my gosh. For you
is freaked out.
So, I think that's her uh imitating her dog. We shouldn't we
shouldn't laugh at that one quite as much. Okay, that's just
her imitating her dog. Simon's coverage of this today was interesting.
It would be not a Houthie and there is no proof of him being
a Houthy. Are you a soldier? Yes. That seems pretty definitive.
He never said Hassan Nola was a good guy. I can't believe I'm
calling Nola. I lost 10K on stake. You think I can get a loan?
I don't know about that. I gamble with the free money they gave
me and that's it. Gambling isn't my vice, unfortunately. Uh that's
incredibly fortunate for you actually. Now for the fun part.
Let's take a look at the complaints and let's start with my favorite
of the three, the very own. Ethan Klein truly is the Britney
Venty for me. Okay, there's something where I'm like, it's not
always healthy, but there's something so satisfying about watching
a petty [__] be [__] petty. Um, and in
this case, like the lawsuits, I think that I just feel like the
lying to like it's just the constant like marketing, like the
lying to market to save your reputation is just odd to me. could
be actually good for the industry of like erect. What can I say?
I just I feel like lying sucks, man. Feel like lying just sucks.
Standards of being like, "Hey, even when I want to do something
deceptive, I have to be like I have to like let the other person
know. I like have to say I have to say out loud so that the person
can like confirm to other people that I was like doing something
deceptive." Like when I when I called Thomas Fest, I like literally
was like, "Oh yeah, I guess I don't really have a crystal." You
know what? Uh I I'm just like kind of memeing now. I don't really
hold that genuine. I don't think you're like a danger to women,
right? And I was like I like literally added Mantis in like spicy
chat or something. I was like, "You should tell Tom this that
I like made this statement. You should you should take a screenshot
cuz I'll always agree with this." Okay. Except that ended up
being true. Well, we kind of wished it into reality. Sort of
like when Hassan was like, "Ethan's mentally ill." And then that
just got wished into reality. It's up what streaming will do
to people sometimes. Okay. You just like there's like some weird
juju in the air. You just make things come true. Anyway, you
can't just take all of people's content, not direct it back to
them, and then do so explicitly and maliciously. You can't do
that. That's bad. It's not allowed. Um, but also, damn, it's
petty. The prestigious, the highly acclaimed, the highly analytical
Casey Trron. A lot of people have been wanting to watch this.
Okay. Uh, it looks like we've reached the end of the stream,
guys. We're here at the end of the stream. I will be back tomorrow.
All right. We'll be back for more content. All right, we're going
to go I'll probably just jump into another call. I'll let people
like ask questions and stuff. We'll see what's up. I'll figure
out like some piece of content if nothing else. If if nothing
else, I'll jump in. We'll do um like a Q&A or something.
All right.
All right. All right. Uh we will be back tomorrow. I'm going
to grab some food. I'm not totally sure. We'll see what content
we're going to do in the oil call. All right. Not 100% sure.
Not 100% sure. Okay. Oh, also guys, if you are looking for content,
there is the there's the whole stream from last night, okay?
I did seven hours after the first stream. There's like probably
seven hours of VOD from last night that you may not have watched.
So, if you're looking for more content, you're looking for me
just to like talk about stuff more, there is like a whole 7 hour
VOD from last night. If you missed it, which I think a lot of
people did, you can go ahead and watch it. Okay, so have a good
one. Love you guys. And I will be back tomorrow.
Nick, I know the answer to that question, but you can never ever
know. I was sworn to secrecy.
It's incredibly juicy. Okay, it's incredibly juicy gossip. Incredibly
hot goss. All right, but I can never tell you. I can never talk
about it ever in a million years. I was sworn to secrecy. So,
I just wanted to I just wanted to say that it was an incredibly
juicy secret and then bounce. Okay, so I love you guys. I'll
be back tomorrow. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Good night.